it's friday and that means it's time for
friday follies and for that we turn to
fox news contributor raymond arroyo all
right raymond it's hard days for
superheroes i understand it is it's a
bird it's a plane it's a cancellation
laura
batgirl this hundred million dollar film
epic it was scrapped by warner brothers
this week the film featured leslie
grace's batgirl michael keaton returning
as a very creaky caped crusader and
brendan fraser is the villain but the
movie was totally canned following test
screenings now
it was something i can imagine training
well who needs test screenings like the
trailer had
what when you looked at it it had bat
bomb written all over it
you keep this up you're gonna die
well matthew balani laura who hosts
spotify's the town podcast he spoke to
someone who attended this batgirl
screening wasn't received well
he said that after the screening the
executives walter hamada of dc and some
of the others there asked the audience
you know did this feel big and the
consensus was absolutely not he said it
played like a tv pilot the stakes were
very small
laura they threw millions and millions
of dollars warner brothers did at this
it was originally kind of a small movie
they threw 100 million dollars and when
they screened it it was so flat they
decided to take the tax right off it's
not even being shown on hbo max nothing
no coverage
i don't know anything about this but if
i were to guess i would guess that the
lead was flat well maybe who knows
you'll never get to see it but here's
the interesting thing but she's not even
in the promo no you barely see her there
32 in a new morning consult poll
32 percent of marvel comic fans think
they're getting a little tired of so
many superhero movies so ah
maybe off the rose the cash cow things
are so unstable at dc for the
superheroes jason mamoa aquaman has
apparently started a side hustle as a
flight attendant he's no longer plunging
into water he's giving it out and there
he is
[Music]
[Applause]
you're doing such a great uh you're
doing such a great job
i'm not a big fan of man buns but i make
an exception for him oh you need rebecca
oh okay yeah so does sam by the way she
just said oh yeah extra water shoot
extra water water another did you just
didn't you just have a water oh just
another one i'd like another yeah okay
well superheroes are not the only ones
underwater lore we've been reporting for
weeks the dangerous side of theme parks
from riots to brawls family come apart
well this week at disney world it's not
only a small world but a torturous one
not only did the ride known as the
happiest cruise on that ever sailed trap
visitors in their boats for over an hour
but one of them started to sink
you know laura this attraction was built
for the 1964 world's fair it was
probably built when the bmi was a little
bit lower than it is today that's like
how they have to make the extra wide
coffins now for people right and
apparently
that no one was hurt right no no one was
hurt so as it was slowly submerging
itself
apparently the music kept going so
that's a nice that's the watch but
that's the most torturous part of all to
have to sit there and listen to that
song for over an hour just imagine that
these people should get free passwords
everyone i got stuck on it's a small
role and i didn't get off for almost an
hour and 15 minutes that was like
several years ago yes and that music i
think that i couldn't get it out of my
head for in all the puppets moving back
and forth i think it was all a micro and
macro aggression all right speaking of
uh sinking ships the democrats that was
so easy are so desperate for someone to
rescue them from biden that their great
sages like
bill crystal are pushing
john legend to run for president oh this
is good even old political hands like
david axelrod laura seemed drawn to this
possibility of legend as political
messiah he appeared on axelrod's podcast
and was asked about his friendship with
kanye west well you know we aren't
friends as much as we used to be because
i honestly think because we
publicly disagreed on
his running for office his supporting
trump i think it became uh
too much for
us to sustain our friendship honestly
so he's the most
i mean intolerant person out there this
is the typical liberal they claim to be
so tolerant and open aren't we woke
aren't we in the end they're snobs if
you don't agree with them they want no
party i just don't like the idea that
you end french over political
differences that's not the way america
works and certainly not a leader but you
know the greatest obstacle to legend
ever being president or pursuing
politics can really be described in two
words chrissy teigen can you imagine
this woman as first lady
i think it's possible to be really angry
all the time if there was one word you
would help
particularly women
use more frequently what would that one
word be
[ __ ] you
sorry
first of all
she's having a baby which is awesome and
she had some struggles of that so that's
fantastic
the
the
desperation on the part of democrats is
so palpable
in going
there well and they've been trying to
rehabilitate chrissy teigen for a number
of years since she told that teenager go
kill yourself again when you disagree
with somebody
wishing them death or ending friendships
probably not the right way to go she did
apologize but i i i just don't know if
this has political legs i think it's got
as much float to it as one of those
small worlds a legend in their own mind
legends in their own mind raymond arroyo
it's so fun to be in the studio just
exuding positivity as always all right
raymond thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else